[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So it's my pleasure
to introduce Aaron Draplin.
He's got a new book out called
"Pretty Much Everything"
about the mid-career tenure
of his design career,
and that's available
in the back, as well.
Aaron's awesome.
He's got a fantastic
Marc Maron podcast out
if you haven't listened to it.
That will pretty much
show you that he's just
so inspired by everything
that has to do with design
and is so passionate about it
that it rubs off on everybody.
So without any further ado,
let's welcome Aaron, please.
[APPLAUSE]
AARON DRAPLIN: This side of the
room, settle down over there.
That side and all those people.
Hi, everybody.
Hello.
Hi.
This is so-- no.
I gotta use this thing today.
OK, everybody, thank
you for coming.
I mean, of all
the surreal things
you get to do in your life to--
I use the product.
Thank you.
Good job.
We're here.
We're broadcasting all over the
world, and this is a book talk.
I got to make a
book, and let me test
my multimedia real quick here.
How's that?
RGB is looking
pretty good, and let
me get to that mosaic filter.
How we looking in
the back there?
Everyone look OK?
All right?
Good.
Because I don't know
if you know what I do.
I mean, there are
definitely faces here
just doing that
kind of thing where
you're wondering
where you're at,
and you're wondering why
you're looking at me.
It's OK.
I'm a person.
I come from a family.
My name is Aaron James Draplin.
I'm 43 years old.
I'm a graphic designer.
I live in Portland, Oregon.
And I come from a mom, and a
dad, and sisters, and shit,
an almost brother-in-law,
and I have a girlfriend.
Oh, is she lovely.
Look at her just
little bright spot
in the back there just radiating
beauty, and intelligence,
and grace.
Her name is Leigh.
When you see this
in the book, this
is a spread that I didn't
get paid any money.
And why I loved that is because
I made a life in graphic design
where it wasn't always about
just cash, or big jobs,
or whatever.
It was about the power
sometimes of your mouse finger
and how it could
affect your buddy.
And then maybe there's a couple
of things I got paid for,
but they're all there, and you
wouldn't know about that stuff
because maybe you would
know about me making logos.
I would hope so.
I love to make logos, and
I've kept myself super busy.
9 out of 10 of these
were just for fun.
In a lot of ways, I
tricked graphic design
into hiring me by keeping
myself busy because then people
couldn't tell what was the
big job or the little job,
and then when someone big calls
reacting to something that I
did for my buddy, I
manifested a life--
I tricked them in so many ways.
Now, if you know
about Field Notes,
well, these are
all over Manhattan.
These are all over Brooklyn,
all over the whatever, New York
City, and we're
up to 2000 stores,
but this was just because
I couldn't find ones
that I liked.
So I made my own.
Now, there's no
license for that.
I just made my own, and
we're 13 employees now,
which is really crazy.
It could've just been me,
but we're a thing now.
All these years later,
I've been making
posters for all these
places I've been able to go.
I'm up to about 46
of the 50 states.
Me and the Virginias, we're
not talking right now,
but instead of putting my face
on one of these posters for one
of the shows I've
been able to go do,
we would make something for
Iowa that was a little bit more
like maybe your mom
and dad would like it--
dead logos, dead things,
colloquialisms, little sayings,
and weird things that I
would dig up from my travels,
or photos, or stuff.
So maybe you know about
those or all the merch
I've made over the years.
And there was no
bottom line to this
that it was supposed to
be this thing where I
was supposed to make a profit.
No, this was all just for fun.
And I use all this stuff.
That's rule number one.
It has to be real, but there's a
charm to getting a ice scraper,
or there's a charm to
getting a patch or a sticker.
Well, I couldn't
call it the chip
clip due to proprietary reasons,
but it's called a snack clamp
at the DDC.
You all eat chips,
so just settle down.
That side of the
room, you really
got to just back off
just a little bit.
Thanks.
It's called crowd control.
Now, if you know about me
messing with dead logos,
I love dead logos, and
you'll find a logo today
when we were at the Con Edison--
that's a classic New York logo,
and on the side of every cab
that's a classic New York logo.
And if you know
how to look, it's
out there, but these are these
little diamonds of complete--
there's not one
pretentious element to it,
and you guys know.
You guys are inventing the web.
I'm trying to make
a living, whatever,
and it's like sometimes there's
just so much icing on the cake.
And when you're out there,
I love taking photos
of dead stuff and in a
delusional sense using
this in my work.
So maybe you've seen this on
my Instagram or over the years
me championing these things,
because when it goes away,
we're going to be at
the mercy of clicks,
and likes, and
aggregated things,
and then everything is a fucking
"Star Wars" remix poster.
So that's kind of
where we're at.
If you've seen one of these
shows, today is number 300.
I think it's 300 in
the last six years.
I have gone everywhere.
We will be putting a dot
in Jackson Hole on the way
back out west this year.
All of this stuff-- if
you know about me or not,
it's all packed into a book.
I got to make a book on a big
city New York City publisher.
This is a new talk.
It's called "We Got a Book
Deal!" or, well, our chance
to tell you about the
harrowing account,
but I didn't get into graphic
design to make a book.
I got into graphic
design to make a living,
and that's just the
best way to put it.
I know the people
who got into it to--
I get to be
backstage with them--
who talk a certain different--
just a different way
have such a certitude
how good they are
and how deserved they are
of making books and shit.
If it didn't happen, I was cool.
I had a great life in
graphic design already.
I made that happen for myself
and my buddies around me,
but I got to make this thing.
So I got this call to the big
leagues, and that's Abrams.
They're just up on--
I think it's 20th and something.
Not that far from here.
Big city.
But this is a big league deal.
Yesterday I was there.
I was looking through a
Damien Hirst selection.
Damien Hirst is on
some imprint of Abrams,
but people closer to me would be
like Sagmeisters is on Abrams.
Victori was on Abrams.
Those are big names in graphic
design, and art, and thinking,
and sort of these
big provocative guys.
And when I got that call,
I was kind of scared
because I don't weigh
in like they do,
but that's me meeting
John, John Gall, my editor,
and this is me
sealing the deal where
it was like I was afraid to
go do it because in my life
it's OK to say no and be small,
but this was scary territory.
So that's how I threatened
him all summer long--
2015, too.
Well, you get a contract.
You sign that contract.
It goes from zero to
shit's due quick, right?
So everything was
cool up to that point.
Oh, Aaron, we love what
you do and all that shit.
And then it's going.
So I'm cool with that.
I know how to deal
with a client.
I know now how to deal with
a bunch of smart people
in the city who are ready
to get this thing done.
Now, compensation is
weird because all I
was ever concerned about was,
how many books could I get?
Because, yes, you get paid
to just be a part of it,
and that's usually how a
book works is you give all
this stuff in a shoebox like
you die is usually how it works.
And then somewhere
an estate takes
all the big designer, and
name, or artist's work into--
out of her studio or wherever.
They build a book
for the person,
and then the book comes
out on the imprint,
and that's how it goes, but I
was just like, I'm still alive.
And I said, well,
who designs it?
Well, we have two people
here in New York City.
No, no, no.
I dabble in graphic design.
I do.
Who writes it?
Oh, we got this smart
graduate [INAUDIBLE].
I'm writing the fucking book.
So I got paid to
be a part of it,
build it, and then write
it, which meant this.
1,500 books?
All right.
So that's Barnes & Noble price.
That's what I got
paid, and I was cool,
because in the game of
perception, if Abrams sold one,
I knew I had 1,500 to
go push on the road,
or give to all my buddies.
Book number one went to my
mom, so that was worth it,
but then that shit shows up,
and it would fill this stage.
1,500 books-- I don't know
how to use a pallet jack.
We screwed up the
elevator rugs and shit
because I had like 3,000
pounds of books in there,
and whatever, but
it's real easy for me
to get up here in front
of all this lavish crowd.
See, what you guys
can't see on YouTube--
there are 10,000
people sitting here.
Listen to them.
[CHEERING]
There's 11 people.
There's more people
in this fucking photo
than there are in
this whole room.
Just kidding.
I'm just kidding.
So thank you.
It's really easy for me
to be like, I did this.
I did that.
I did.
I'm great.
I made a book and all that shit.
There's a bunch of people
that make these things.
I got to go do
this talk yesterday
to all the people at Abrams
who helped me make my book,
and a year ago I went there.
We're getting ready to
start seeing them show up,
and it was March of last year,
and I thanked every single one
of them hand over a cubicle.
Thank you for believing
me and doing this thing.
It's going to be awesome.
I can't remember their names.
Ronny, Bobby, Ricky,
and Mike, Jackie--
I can't remember all the names.
There are so many people.
They're all good looking,
and healthy, and nice.
There's me and, of course,
John, but I thanked them all,
and I did yesterday, too,
because this wasn't supposed
to happen, and yet they kind
of say authors didn't even
come into the office sometimes
because that's just business.
Fine, but I'm going to haunt
all these people the rest
of their lives with
this thing, and I
have to thank them for
letting me do this.
Now, the schedule was weird.
I thought it would
take two years.
No, no, no.
We did it in about
three and a half months.
I got the call in
November of 2014.
I bought DDCbook.com
that afternoon.
Freaked out.
Signed the contract five
months later in March of 2015.
We started the book
in June of 2015.
Had it done by September.
Handed off by November.
Printing January of last
year, and it came out May 17.
So this idea of I got to
build, and write, and design,
and compile for about three
and a half months, and then
just the process of whittling
down all the typos and things,
and the first printing had 26,
but it took three months just
to get it ready to hand
off, and that's just
called being published.
The basic elements are
really, really simple.
See, there's a bit of
a chip on my shoulder
because it's a great privilege
to be here with you guys.
It's a great privilege
to have the book.
in a weird way
to have people come after
you because they know
your name because you have
this book or something,
or because they know your
name from some poster
site or something.
And I read all the comments.
I'm a human being, and the idea
that I'm going to call this
a mid-career survey--
that just sounds so official.
I wanted to show this.
Pack in as much as possible
all the shit I pulled off,
but it's kind of a chip on
the shoulder, because, listen,
for every little turd
who's come after me--
grad students--
and come after me
because I've tried to
live a life creatively
and tried to live a
life ethically working
for clients I like and make
things I like even to a loss,
I'm a target.
And I read that shit
as a human being.
So making this book in a
lot of ways was a lot of--
one kid said that
Draplin's a one trick pony.
I'll never forget that,
because I was like, well,
there's about 16 in
that stage coach.
I'm a little biased, but
it's like, man, you can't--
he doesn't know about this.
That kid didn't--
I made snowboard
magazines for seven years,
but what's important is I
know my way around a grid,
and snowboarding
doesn't look like that.
Snowboarding,
skateboarding, and shit--
I mean, it's wild and
stuff, but we made our mag
so you could actually read
it, and read the articles,
and look at the photos, and not
have it just bombarded with all
the latest tricks and shit.
Now, that could
have been maybe--
if I dare-- a
dwell or something,
the things that I aspire to,
but they don't know that I
know my way around a grid.
They don't know that.
So how do you go back?
They don't know.
If you look at the top
row on the top right,
that's not chicks in bikinis.
That's a women's issue we
made, and the women had their--
we let them go for it.
We're not there
to mess with them.
We're there to say you're just
as valid on the hill as we are.
Go.
And they had their
women's issue,
and it was super cool because--
see, they don't know
about that shit.
I'm proud of that.
That's in the book.
They don't know about 12 years
with Coal Headwear, where
it started with two
of us in a basement,
and there's 20 or
30 kids there now.
They don't know
about that stuff.
I did every hang tag
for a decade on a hat,
or every year for Union Binding
Company we'd make 50 logos.
They don't know
about this stuff.
So to be-- they're
like cheap shots.
I've just learned the internet
is forever, at least right now,
and when you leave
that stuff, that's what
you're going to be known for.
And it takes all my strength
not to go back to that kids.
So making the book was kind of
a big old hairy, well, whatever.
I know my way around the grid.
Here's all the stuff I got to
make, and it's a simple system.
It's some typefaces.
It's a simple grid,
something there,
write an essay, big old hit of
orange, some tricky content.
That's my nephew,
Oliver, six years old.
First tooth just came out.
So cute.
That's the light of our
lives, my nephew, Oliver.
Last summer's lowest points--
well, it should say--
yeah, this was summer 2015,
but I worked every day
that day, because it
was my shot to do it.
And this shit that--
I was forced to do this.
First of all, they came to me.
They came to me.
I didn't go to them.
I'm not going to go knocking--
a lot of kids ask me,
how did you submit your
work to get into a book?
I was like, what are
you talking about?
This was a record deal.
They gave me the record deal.
So when it was my shot to go do
it, I'm not screwing that up.
I was scared.
I was on a contract, but
I would leave the house,
rip down to the shop in
Portland, work all day,
and go home at 4:00
in the morning.
And when I would go home
at 4:00 in the morning,
I wouldn't even put my pants on.
I would just drive
home with no pants on,
and then it got so
weird that summer--
hello, to this side of the
room, all of you other 3,000.
Hi.
Hey.
I wasn't wearing pants on
the way to the job at 7:45
in the morning, which is
a little tricky getting
onto the elevator out of
the basement at the shop.
So no complaints, though.
No complaints.
I mean, I just worked
all day, 17, 18 hours.
Now listen.
Behind every 586
pound graphic designer
who is probably getting
a ticket, triple parked
in Brooklyn right now,
probably, well, not debatable,
chafed, here in the city
sweating-- behind every one
of those graphic designers,
at least right now,
is a patient,
patient girlfriend,
and her name is Leigh McKolay.
And she's right there.
Just a little bright spot.
Just a little butter cream icing
rose on a big orange turd cake.
Look at her.
Isn't she just lovely?
And please get a nasty
Prince song in your head
right now, something real wet.
You got it?
Because look at her.
Isn't she lovely?
Isn't she?
God, what did you guys expect
for what you're paying?
Look at her.
Look how sweet.
She's three there.
Look at the symmetry.
What is she doing
with me, right?
Graphic design
took me to Berlin.
Leigh got hammered on that first
class trip over there back.
It was great.
She likes to sing, and I don't
even know what a salt cave is,
but that's the one person that
summer that really made sure
that I didn't eat out
of a bag every night,
and would bring me stuff
to work, or get me home,
and I would have a somewhat
regular meal for dinner,
and then work late.
So I have to thank her,
because we're on this tour,
and this shit's not easy.
I'm 43 years old.
Leigh is-- I'm not
going to get into it,
but I want you to see
this because this is cool.
She has shacked up.
Gone right to the muck, and is
in it with me in this thing.
And poor girl, but
she's around resources
because I'm doing this
stuff all the time.
And that turd, Don Trump, no
one voted for him here, right?
For the crowd who's not here,
not one even motion of--
because if you did, you're
complicit, but she's pissed.
Don Trump rattled
the wrong cage,
and she made these
little postcards.
And we're selling them
at our merch table.
Not today, but on the
road on this tour,
but that's my favorite one.
Wait until our periods sync up.
So you can send this to
your senator or congressman,
and tell them that
they're stupid,
and Leigh will
facilitate that for you
on her little post card.
She's already raised two grand
for the ACLU with this thing.
So if you go to
notes_to_self, you
can see her project starting.
This is a person,
and she's pissed,
and she's fighting
back creatively.
And that's a lesson for all
of us and definitely me.
I don't know what to do.
I'm afraid of that turd.
So I don't know what to do, but
thank you, Leigh, for coming
today.
Thank you for
coming on this tour.
Here's a shop tour.
Now, that's the shop.
That's it.
That's where I get to be.
There's no reception.
There's no "Star Trek" doors
you walk through like we just
did 40 seconds ago.
I saw them.
It was cool.
There was credentials and shit.
I get it.
We're at Google.
Now, those are my two partners.
That's John Phemister.
That's Dave Nakamoto.
There's no pants if you
don't want pants at my shop.
I got to be with my buddies
for 10 years in this shop,
and I love them for it because
this wasn't about some--
who hates you boss here?
And no one's raising their hand.
It's all being recorded.
Who hates their boss here?
Couple half hands.
Well, there's no boss here.
We take care of each
other, and I'm just
so proud to even show
that I got to do it
in this with my buddies,
and get away with it,
and make a killer living.
Take care of myself, and my
mom, and my dad, and Leigh,
and my sisters, and shit here,
amongst all my little trinkets,
and goodies, and stuff.
This exists.
I've gone to all
these cool places
and saw cool cubicles and stuff.
I know.
But I can tell you this.
I raced to get to
my shop every day,
and I'm proud to even say that.
That exists.
Who's got a book?
He's flipping right now.
It's a random page
flip, and he landed on--
good job.
My summer has a carny.
Do we have any
carnies in the crowd?
What is this thing?
Do we have any
carnies in the crowd?
Well, I was a carny one summer.
That would be 1994.
I went out west as
a youngster in '93
to be a snowboarder with
all my asshole buddies,
and how we got out there
was we had summer jobs
and all summer of '93.
Went out the winter of '93, 19
years old, me and my buddies.
If you haven't
done that yet where
you move somewhere crazy--
now, usually I'm telling this
to 22 year olds in a college--
but if you haven't
done it yet, go do it,
because it'll be
better when you're
24 than when you're 43
like me, but we got it out
of our system at 19.
We went and did this.
Went all the way out
west, and then had
to come back with our
tails between our legs
broke and had to
work another summer,
and I got this
job in a carnival.
And it was a traveling deal
all summer long in Michigan,
but there's a hierarchy
to this stuff.
Someone owns all the
rides, and all the stuff,
and books, all the shit,
hires all the carnies,
but they run the thing.
They rent to a food court.
The food court hires us
as sort of college kids.
We work for the food court.
We're in a pizza wagon,
me my buddy, Chad.
We started just a gentleman's
handshake all summer
with our guy.
We're going to work 12
weeks, but underneath that,
are the carnies all
the way at the bottom,
and we're not really supposed
to hang with the carnies.
I mean, they're rough.
They're kind of dirty, whatever.
They're just kind of
hardscrabble people.
But two weeks in, Chad and I,
we're doing our pizza wagon.
We're noticing every night
there's a little table,
and they're giving draws
based on daily earnings.
So if someone worked and
they tore the stuff down,
or they put it all up,
and they ran the ride
with the carnies all day,
at the end of the day,
they've got this little table.
Get $5, $10, $15, and you do
that every night plus pay.
They were charged to sleep in
these little air conditioned
sleeper units or something.
Well, here's the deal.
Three weeks in, every
night Chad and I-- we
would cavort with the carnies.
We'd take them in
our truck into town
to go hit a supermarket, because
if you're not doing that,
you're eating elephant ears
and pizza all summer long.
And that kind of
worked for some people,
but we were going in
to kind of stock up.
So we'd put people in
the back of our truck,
and we became buddies,
and we were hanging out
with the carnies.
I remember one
kid, 31 years old.
He had his 15 or 16
year old kid with them.
Just do the math on that shit.
That's what's going on.
So Chad and I, as
compassionate people,
we're like, oh, all right,
these guys are cool,
but three or four
weeks in getting those
draws we say, hey, how
come you're not coming in
with us tonight to some kid.
And he'd be like,
well, I'm broke.
At the end of those two weeks or
whatever, they're taken a draw.
They're getting the charge for--
some guys would be in
tents outside of their vans
driving along to save money.
All that shit's taxed,
and sometimes people
would owe money to the carnival.
They'd be like, what
are you talking about?
They'd work it off I guess
the next couple of days,
but you know what?
I had a mom and dad.
I had a little bit of college.
I had direction.
I had this wanderlust
to go west.
These kids don't have that.
I had a support system.
My mom and dad didn't cut
me a check to go west.
We worked all summer,
but I had them help me
when I came back just to give
me my old room back or whatever.
And it's like I had their
creative support and teeth
care, and these kids didn't.
And Chad and I watched
this shit go down,
and we're watching people make
some bad decisions, maybe,
because it's kind of like--
I don't know-- a gentle
indentured servitude
or something.
Those carnies still have to
put those rides back together.
These people were
legacied into this shit.
So Chad and I, like a couple
of dumbasses from Midwest
with a heart--
we started watching,
and we started stealing.
And how we did it is, when a
guy would come $4.75 Mountain
Dew this big.
Give me a $5 bill.
I'm supposed to give
him a quarterback.
I'd give him change for a
$20, and we Robin Hooded
that shit the rest of the summer
and took care of these guys.
And here's the deal.
Do we have any
paralegals in the crowd
that know amusement law
in Northern Michigan?
Do we have any of that?
Because I don't know
what the word is.
Fuck it.
I published the thing.
I'm like, I'm gonna get
my teeth knocked out
or something when I go--
from some guy who's
pissed that I stole money
from them all summer long in
'94 to take care of the carnies.
Got a tough crowd.
I know lunch hour
is in 19 minutes.
What do you see?
Is this even fun?
I just don't know.
People are checking-- landing
planes off of laptops and shit.
I don't know.
We're human beings.
I talk.
I say things.
You listen.
You react.
Now look it, when
I made Field Notes,
I made them with my hands.
Based on this stuff, these
are ghosts of the Midwest.
Your grandpa, who had
them in his pocket--
that worked 100 years ago,
and it still works now.
My phone, when it gets like
12%, I'm really uneasy,
and that's a new thing.
Little kids are born now.
Their hands like
this in the womb,
and they wake-- you're
gonna plug that shit
in their hand [INAUDIBLE].
It's true.
We're putting dots on a map with
our little Field Notes project.
This is ours.
It's ours.
Any profit is ours.
Any losses, it's ours.
There's no board or
nothing like that.
It's ours, and
it's a great lesson
that we can invent these
things for ourselves,
because when I got free from
clients, and things, and stuff,
that's where I got to use
my earnings to go and invent
my life.
That whole story about how
we made those is in the book,
but I love to show a
spread in the book which
is totally vulnerable.
This is every Field Note I had
in my pocket for the last 10
or 11 years or
whatever, and it's
like to show that in the book
was really important to me
because I want to
demystify how you make
these things,
because, listen, I get
to go be around the
people who totally
know how to talk this shit up.
But really, it was there--
me making notes on paper.
And that's where I was free,
and I could be organized,
make a list.
Who here still makes a grocery
list on a scrap of paper?
People do because it works.
You go into Whole Foods--
whole paycheck--
you go in there,
and you can't concentrate.
There's just a million things.
That worked for your
grandma and your grandpa,
and that works for us.
And we forget that,
because our phones.
I get it, but I love
to show that when
I had a sticker from a banana
I stuck it in my Field Notes.
That's design, too, on a banana.
And you can learn what it's
like to be packed on a plane.
There it is.
So that's where it was--
me drawing in my Field
Notes for all these years,
and making a list, and
scratching everything off,
and feeling free at
the end of the day
because it's not the
same with a swipe.
It's not the same.
When my phone dies, I can't
handle it, but on paper--
when they make you put your
laptop away on the plane,
out come my field notes, and
I'd make way better ideas there.
There's me and Jim Coudal,
my captain, the den mother,
my brother, who's really steered
this thing into something good.
They're all over Manhattan.
They're all over the nation,
and I have to thank him,
because my stupid little
non-idea became a real thing,
and the whole story is in there.
Today this came out.
When I saw this in
Hollandale, Mississippi,
it just was so beautiful to
me-- this corrugated sign,
the delinting factory
sign thing, the typeface.
I was like, man,
what is that thing?
It's so simple.
It's based on how many--
the grid of the corrugated
lines of this thing.
So here's the first F word.
It's so functional and perfect.
And I just took a
photo, and that night
in my hotel room on
Highway 61 in Mississippi
I went looking for it,
and couldn't find it,
couldn't find it,
couldn't find it.
So fuck it.
I built it, and I built
that thing 2004, 2005.
10 years I used it out
of Illustrator and would
hunt and peck.
If I needed Google--
G-O-O-G-L-E-- and build it,
and use it in something,
until Riley Cran got his
hands on it from Lost Type.
Built it into a beautiful,
beautiful three weight
character set.
It works for 100 languages.
It came out today.
When you open my phone on
the way over, I put it up.
Last night they put
it up, and then I
put my links up this
afternoon on my "instagrizz"
and all that--
this morning on my
"instagrizz," and you
could just see the
things just flying in.
We built a typeface, and I
mean, we got a site lit for it,
but talk about revival.
Now, see this is going to be
posted somewhere, but with all
those kids who are
buying DDC hardware
with my little typeface today--
what they don't know, they're
getting a free poster.
That comes right
out of my pocket,
and that free poster
has decimal equivalents
because that's where this
stuff was meant to work.
This isn't cool, but we don't
have this kind of typeface
that's just meant to
be un-fuck-with-able.
We don't have that.
Now, I know you've got
a nice bunch of Google
typefaces and all that.
Good.
That shit's great.
It looks good this big
on a phone and shit.
Great.
But I want these things to
be looked to look shitty
when it says park
here, because when
someone grabs one of your
beautiful articulate web
faces and tries to
do it with that,
it doesn't work sometimes.
So we built this thing
to work vertically,
you or we have the
ogonek and [INAUDIBLE]
for thank you in Polish.
I'm sure I'm butchering
that, but there's the ogonek,
that little E thing.
We have diacritics to
work for 100 languages.
So I'm proud of that.
This thing can go
all over the world,
and whether or not it
sells, it's revival.
I saw something
that didn't exist.
I acted on it.
It's not to be ironic.
It's meant to just
be functional.
So that came out today.
So go check it out--
DDC Hardware.
It'll be all over
my feed and stuff.
That's going today.
My favorite story from the book.
My dad, 1983-- I'm
nine years old.
Takes me to a tigers
game with my uncles.
I'm there.
I'm nine.
I'm a third baseman.
You got your jersey,
your hat, your glove,
and I remember going in.
It's Polish-American
night, so my dad,
who wasn't much of a drinker--
he liked to play up he was.
Wasn't much of a drinker.
My dad had a couple beers that
night, was feeling no pain,
and I remember we get there,
and he's a little wobbly.
And I remember him
saying, don't worry, punk.
I'm going to get you a ball.
My cousins who are with
me, they don't want nothing
to do with a 9 year old.
They take me down
to the railing.
Get a-- I don't know--
batting practice ball, nothing.
We go out to center field.
Couple balls are
bouncing around where
they're hitting homers and
shit, batting practice.
Kids are diving for them.
I'm nine.
I don't know what to do.
Now, 1983-- I don't have a
photo of my dad, but I do
have one from 2003,
and there's my dad,
and I like to call
this shot mid-sip.
So my dad says, I'm going
to catch you a ball.
And it's first
inning, second inning,
you sing in the seventh,
and then eighth inning,
ninth inning.
Ron Hassey's up to
bat, knocks one back.
Foul ball.
Top of the dugout, third base
dugout-- we're behind that.
Bounces in front of us
two rows or something.
My dad dives with his
beer, catches the ball.
My uncles lift him up.
Doesn't spill the beer, and
my dad caught me a ball,
and he put it in my lap.
And he goes, I told you I was
going to get you a ball, Aaron.
He Babe Ruth-ed that shit,
and that's in the book.
That's in the book.
Now, we have a
little extra time.
Turns out my dad did that
with a puck at a Red Wing
game for my Uncle Kevin 10 years
before me, so that is amazing.
Another favorite section--
they're drawing me now.
What am I supposed to do when
they hand you this shit at one
of these shows?
I don't know.
Look, they hand
you that portrait.
It's like this big.
I'm not putting that up in my
office, but it was emotional.
Look at the likeness.
It's so crazy, and
that's my buddy John
Hammer in Tulsa, an incredible
painter, illustrator.
Just an incredible person.
I don't know him that well,
but I'll love him forever
for him doing that of me,
and now when I'm gone,
I guess Nakamoto, Leigh--
Dave put this up on my desk.
Because I'm gone for 10 weeks,
so when the people come in,
they're like, why does he
have a painting of himself
on his desk?
That's there.
They're embroidering me now.
Yeah.
When they hand you that one--
this is a buddy in Portland.
I love them, but the eyes
are all wonky and shit.
I know he did it on purpose,
but you just love them,
and you say it's perfect.
You put them on your Instagram,
and then, of course, this.
Bleh.
This is in the book.
Two spreads dedicated to all
the guys and girls who drew me,
and I thank them,
and it's so cool.
We fought for this.
The book is $40.
It had to be affordable.
MoMA today-- we're
going to go see it. $40.
You bought it Amazon
preorder-- it was $24.
I was so thankful.
Will this thing support me?
Sorry.
S
$0.16 a page, not bad.
It's amazing.
I fought for that.
We made little
sticker sheets that
went with it when we were done.
This isn't Abrams.
This is me.
I just ponied up and
did these things.
I made a little slip
case that was beautiful,
and we saw these at
the shows, because I
wanted an American made slipcase
to hold this little gem.
And those were
made in Wisconsin,
and they were perfect,
and I made those.
We sold a mountain of them
the day the book came out.
And we're on a book tour.
Now look at her on
that orange van.
Look at her.
Buttercream icing rose.
Now we're going everywhere.
Today's 300.
I have to update this shit, but
we have gone so many places.
Last fall alone we did 34 shows,
seven weeks, 12,000 miles.
It was awesome, because, listen,
I went yesterday to Abrams,
people don't go on book tours.
I'm going on a book tour.
I wasn't supposed to
get to make a book.
I'm supposed to go do a tour.
We already did it.
In the next two months, shit,
we're going to all these places
right here.
I mean, we're halfway through.
I don't even know where
the hell Hampton Roads is.
Does anyone know where that is?
I don't even know.
They signed the contract.
I'm going.
I can't wait.
And we're going to
Newfoundland, and we
got to come here
and tell our story.
We're in a tour van.
It is quadruple
parked in Brooklyn.
It's orange.
It's orange, and listen,
it's a book tour.
What do you do?
Do you put a graphic on
the side of that thing?
My buddies all came out.
Hey, hey, we could wrap it.
We could do this.
I don't know.
Should I be conversational?
Should I just kind of hard sell?
Kind of Massimo
Vignelli influence.
Sort of just van.
Graphic design.
Thick lines, posters, and shit.
Or tonight in that
halfway house these two
are at right here-- these two
are at that halfway house,
and it's court ordered.
And they get out of Google.
They go back to
the halfway house.
They get in the
meds and all that,
and then they get in there, and
the doors lock, and it's OK.
They're healing, and they're
in there in their rooms.
They look out their window,
look through the chains and all
this.
They look out the window, and
idling in the drive is that.
No, that's the van.
MAACO orange.
It's got a MAACO
factory paint job.
So much money, but it's
orange all the way through.
You open the doors up,
it's all the way orange.
So awesome.
When I roll it tonight in
the Holland Tunnel going
fast with 3,000 pounds of
books in that fucker, well,
it'll look like that.
So some numbers.
First printing was sold out
before the book came out
May 17, 2016.
Right away they go
into second printing.
The third printing went
at the end of last summer.
The fourth printing
went about a month ago.
We're at eight months
into this thing,
and it's in its fourth printing,
and I can't talk about it,
but if you've ever been
to Cadillac, Michigan
at peak season in the summer,
there's about 31,000 people,
but I can't really
talk about the numbers.
So in Grapevine,
Texas, we saw my book
on the bottom of the shelf right
next to "Design Basics Index,"
and I just stood there
and kind of like--
Leigh was at the
Starbucks, and I just
stood there kind of
crying, like, holy shit.
My book is at Barnes & Nobles.
It's at MoMA.
That's the coolest, but you
can get it at a Barnes & Nobles
in Grapevine, Texas.
And I stood there.
I flipped out seeing
that, and then of course I
cleaned off all that shit at
the top row, put mine up there,
and ran out.
So I got to go quick.
I got to make a
logo for Mr. Obama.
I vote for human
rights and shit,
so I was excited to help him.
We saw a shit change
that day in 2009.
Who went?
Well, Leigh and I were
there representing
the good people of Google.
I was a fan of this.
I loved this.
I loved what he represented.
I loved intelligence,
grace, cool.
That meant that to me.
This was a new kind of campaign,
a new kind of president,
and he got it.
And I was so proud
to support him.
Now I get this call
from these guys saying,
hey, on a Wednesday, want to
make a logo for the president?
Now, what are you talking about?
This is a Wednesday.
These guys are
calling from Chicago.
Now, I'm not supposed to
make stuff for him like this.
Me and my buddy Chris Glass
made these logos for America.
We did it over [INAUDIBLE]
days, busted them out
in my home town where the
good old boys-- and there's
good old boys in New
York, and there's good
old boys in stupid
Michigan, whatever--
they say horrific
things about Mr. Obama.
I get it, but I
was at that thing.
I said, well, you're back to
work on the road commission.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, I did the logo
for the road commission
you're back on for what
you just called him.
So that's a weird
little thing, but I
got to work not just for
liberals, and blue, and shit.
I got to work for America.
When Fox News got us,
we had death threats
because I worked for an
anti-Christ president.
That's real.
I have the emails.
Four days later, Mr. Obama--
President Obama shows
our logos to America.
We did it four days over a
weekend, my buddy, Chris Glass,
and I. We got to
work for our country.
Now this is my greatest--
it's all downhill from there,
but I wanted to meet him,
and I'm on the road entertaining
precisely this section
of the crowd, people
like you guys.
People like you
guys-- work release.
Work release.
I get it.
I'm out there entertaining those
guys, and Leigh's back home,
and we get the nod, and she
gets to go meet the pres
at the airport in Portland.
And she goes, and she
does her best Jackie O,
and gets all dressed
up, and rips down there.
And I'm on the road
entertaining them,
and she gets to meet the pres,
and I didn't, and I'm still
pissed.
And after this shot,
he's right here,
and you can't put your
phone in his face.
All the Secret Service
tell you not to.
And he goes to the next
one, and there he was.
And she gets to her
car 20 minutes later,
and she's near tears.
We believed.
Now what?
And we're terrified, but
for those eight years
I was so proud of him.
And then ho ho--
and then last summer.
I got you all right where I
want-- right in the pocket.
I got you right where I
want you in that little--
by the way, I've got
to tell you something.
I've got a whole new
life going right now.
I've got a whole new life going.
You know what I discovered?
A whole expanse of freedom,
comfort, and movement.
Stretch denim.
I did.
And I've got you in that
little pocket right there.
Right where I want you.
So then we got to
Sea-Tac last year.
You know what lands?
I'm there in my best Cabela's
bargain cave sweatshirt
or whatever.
He gets off the plane.
He comes down.
He shakes the hands of all
the dignitaries in town--
Seattle.
Comes running up to us.
Gets about me to the corner
of the stage, and I just--
oh shit, I started
crying, because it was--
it's Barack, and
I believed in him.
When he got to us, he
gets to Leigh right here.
They know each other.
Hey, Leigh.
Hey, Barack.
Fucking fist bumping and shit.
When he got to me, all I could
say was, I'm going to miss you,
man.
That's what I told him.
Now, I'm crying my
eyes out right there.
And I guess because
he kind of took
pity on me I got the handshake.
I got the hand clap.
Leigh says he even hit me in
the shoulder, kind of buck
up kind of moment,
but if we go back one,
look at the face of that
Secret Service agent.
That is not the
face of security.
That is pity because
I'm crying my eyes
out meeting the leader
of the free world
just to say thanks for
having fucking dignity.
He did.
You can't take that
shit away from him.
And this new turd we have--
now what?
Well, I got to work
for Bernie, too.
I got to make three posters
for Bernie, which was so cool.
And then a year ago,
we came to the Bowery,
and we went and saw an art
show with all of our names.
And we got to see, and then
he shows up in his arms,
and elbows, and assholes, or
whatever, and I can't see.
And there's a little bit
of Bernie right there.
And it happened so fast.
And there's my
buddy Luis Calderin
helping him up to his little--
my buddy Louis worked
for him out of Burlington
where Louis is from--
and worked for Bernie,
and got to help him
on his whole campaign.
And then Bernie does his
top 1% whatever, and then
there's Luis looking at me
going, why are you crying,
Draplin?
I'm in the back watching this
shit, and I can't see nothing.
And then he's gone, and
there's lights, and motorcades,
and shit.
And I was digging
around the web,
and I found a photo for proof.
I don't have proof,
but I found proof.
There it is.
I'll do it one more time.
We got-- no, no, no.
We to keep going.
We got to.
Don't forget, you guys,
right this very second,
however you vote, love,
freak out, whatever--
right this very second New
York-- god damn New York City--
we are in a vast, mysterious,
infinite, big old question
mark.
You can go this way
to 141st and Amsterdam
I think it is to where my
cousin Tommy lived up to 19
or whatever when I was 25 years
old the first time I came here.
You can go that way nine miles,
or 86 miles, or whatever it is.
Now you can go this
way to Paramus.
We go to Home Depot in
Paramus six more miles.
Great, great, great.
You can go 666 scrillion
miles this way right
this very second,
and that's real.
This way 666 scrillion
miles, and that's real right
this second right now,
and theoretically we
could you go in this
direction indefinitely,
and that's real right now.
Does anyone think of this shit?
That's real right now.
I know your lives go by
faster here in this big city,
but I think about that shit,
and it brings me to tears,
and it's so beautiful
to me that I
get to be one little mole on the
ass [INAUDIBLE] grand mystery.
That's real, because B--
A says you can go forever.
B says, if you go quick
enough, you get to the edge
as existence is
creating herself,
as it's making
herself out there.
What the hell is it
expanding into right now?
Or if you can go in
one direction forever--
I don't know-- just get cosmic.
And don't forget that shit.
If that turd in the White
House would think this way
just a smidge more, I think
we all could chill out
a little bit but, that's real.
I'm blown away by it.
I don't want you
to forget about.
We got to go quick.
Recent Nasties-- I missed a
space shuttle on unfunny shows,
me telling all the Nike
execs at TEDx Portland
I don't need your money.
Guess who doesn't get
calls from Nike anymore?
It's OK.
New Field Notes and logos.
These are posters that
go to art education Inch
by Inch project out of Indiana--
my buddies Drew and Bob.
My buddy made a
skillet company, Finex,
and I got to do
typing logos for it,
and he's up to 28 employees.
That's so cool.
My dad died.
I got him tattooed on my arm.
It was kind of looking a wonky,
and I got a bloody toothpick
somehow.
I started art directing him.
He got all pissed off.
It's my arm.
Dinosaur JR Poster,
which Hodgman
saw, and I made one for him
for his big comedy tour.
This is right.
My friend Maya and her
incredible little company
she's making up in
Burlington-- it's
going to be called
The Hungry Pea.
This is stuff for Target
for a big art show in Aspen,
but not as cool.
Yeah, it's cool, but it's
kind of like rich people
go to that shit.
I got to do one of the
first GBTA cards for Target
when you check out
because shit's changing,
and I'm so proud to
have helped in that.
This is for Justin Vernon, big
Bon Iver, his big festival.
I got to do the logo
and stuff, but I also
did the backstage
passes that first year.
I know how to make the
crusty stuff as much as I
know how to make the fun stuff.
My last Nike logo I'll
for a Janoski shoe,
which is skateboarding stuff.
I grew up in skateboarding,
and that's a big shoe for them,
and I got to work on that.
That was cool.
Our third skill share is out.
It's going crazy.
My buddy [INAUDIBLE]
just somewhere down here
in lower west side.
And we're going to go see
those guys while we're here.
They put me on a
magazine cover--
how to kill a magazine 101.
Some multimedia.
See?
It wasn't a problem.
Your Google shit was
detecting that there
was something wrong, corrupt.
No, no, no.
It was a multimedia.
Two million on that Vimeo link.
Now little kids come up to me
in the airport with their moms,
and the mom lets her go, and
he little girl comes to me,
and she says, are
you Adam Draklin?
And I said, yeah, yeah.
Hi.
She goes, I want to make
logos when I grow up.
That happened to
me a summer ago.
She saw this video.
Maron let me do his poster
for his show in Portland,
and then he put
me on the podcast.
That's my greatest hit,
so go check that out.
It's real weird.
Polish mugs.
And I've been painting.
I've been painting, and it's
just dumb shit around me.
And my sister Leah's all pissed
because she said I gave her
a neck beard, and whatever.
And look at my nephew, Oliver.
So proud.
He's on the ground.
I'm up on a ladder, and
these are all the signs
we made for my dad's garage sale
last summer, because now I'm
patriarch in training.
And mom says we need
signs, so me and Oliver
get to work that morning.
We make signs.
And do people know when they
were turning into that garage
sale they were being guided
by signs from the hand of one
of the greatest living graphic
designers of this generation.
They don't know that shit.
They don't know that.
Look at the concentration
on his face.
He's at a third
grade reading level.
He's in first grade.
He's OK.
He's healthy.
Don't worry.
He's in good hands.
A woman in Iowa, when
I did this, she goes--
it's a joke.
I went to Guatemala.
That was cool.
So listen, we've got time.
People I've met in
airports and shit.
Look it, I met
Maron in an airport.
He didn't remember,
but I remembered.
Look at the face he made.
Because who am I
walking up to him?
Well, I met him.
Shook his hand.
The catfish dudes.
Chip Kidd.
Before the book, he was like,
you're going to make a book,
and I was like, no way.
And I got to make
a book, and Chip
said it was going to happen.
Neil Hamburger.
I met him.
That was cool.
It was awesome.
John Hodgman.
I was just on John's show last--
couple nights ago in Brooklyn,
which was really fun,
and usually it's
like real people
like Wyatt Cenac and Jason
Sudeikis, and Jon Hamm,
and then something happened.
There was probably a hiccup,
and I got on the show somehow.
That was cool.
He's a buddy.
I just did his new book cover.
If you go look that up,
that came out yesterday.
J Mascis came to my pop up.
I grew up on Dinosaur Jr. I
love Dinosaur Jr. LaFawnduh--
yeah, came to the show.
And then this turd I
met getting on my flight
in Minneapolis down to Des
Moines, and so is Gene Simmons,
but I didn't go shake his hand.
Fuck Gene Simmons.
Well, right before
this, a guy walks up
with a Sharpie and his ticket.
He's like, Mr. Simmons,
I saw you in 19--
I'm right there.
Gene Simmons is right here,
and I'm standing there,
and I can see the dyed
hair, the rock jeans.
I'm looking at him,
and a guy walks up.
He's right there.
And I go-- he says, can
I get you autograph?
And Gene's got his phone.
He goes back to his phone.
I watched that, and I was like,
man, that guy slinking away,
that's who gave you the
$300 million you're worth.
And you can sign his fucking
ticket, but he didn't do it.
But so you know who
you're fucking with,
I'm a Delta diamond
flyer, and I got upgraded,
and I made sure that I just did
one of these onto the big seat.
And I get in the big seat,
and he doesn't, and then
I'm in the big seat when
he comes up the lane,
and then I go, well, hello.
He's [INAUDIBLE].
We get off in Des Moines,
and the whole place
is looking at him, and we
get up to the baggage claim,
and it's all quiet and weird,
and people are looking at him,
and it's fucking Gene Simmons.
And he-- I see him 50 yards away
stop for these three lady cop
things that are on
segues or something,
and he puts his hands against
the wall, and he goes,
frisk me, officer.
I saw that.
And they're like, oh,
Gene, you lady killer.
And he comes walking
up to us, and--
if I fall off this, I just die.
Now, if he comes
walking up to us,
and he gets to
about right there,
and there's this
circle of 100 people--
and he's right there.
And his glasses come off,
and he's kind looking,
and I have all my bags and
shit from the merch table,
and I just walk up, and I
go holy shit, Ted Nugent!
[LAUGHTER]
And just walk out.
So fuck that.
I met Richard Simmons
in an airport.
Look at that.
So, yeah.
Boy, tough crowd, huh?
From Gene Simmons, who sucks,
to Richard Simmons, who rules.
Wake up, New York.
All right, thanks.
When you guys are slumming
later on, go follow me.
I don't care.
I've already been paid.
Thank you.
Buy the book.
We've got a stack out there.
People figured out
how to get this thing.
Go get a book.
They're fun.
I'm a little biased.
Go to the site and get some
merch, but thanks for coming,
you guys, and
listening to this shit.
And this is for my dad
always, so that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
There's so many people it's
hard to wave to them all.
[APPLAUSE]